[Music]
hi everyone welcome back to Friday face
off with me naughty winter Glamour's
beauty editor and the amazing makeup
artist chef well hey guys so the idea is
we have to recreate an iconic makeup
look in just five minutes but the worst
part we don't know what that look is and
I'm actually quite nervous about this
I'm so intrigued about the look based on
the other face offs I've seen I'm very
nervous based on the other face offs
they seem to be getting progressively
more difficult I think so as well
[Music]
I'm actually gonna need some sort of
shower cap or something cuz that's it's
gonna go everywhere I ruined my lashes
everything I'm thinking about the
products with special tools
yeah maybe at the end of a brush or like
if you've got something you can pull
back just sprinkle it on that's a lot of
like splatting I actually can't wait to
do that it's gonna be fun I think it's
gonna look quite cool yeah it is if we
put it on do it well it's gonna look
really cool
[Music]
okay sure what can you think what have
we got okay I've got some gorgeous Pat
McGrath labs eyeshadows which are really
sparkly there's a blue and a power port
gonna use it as my base I think yeah
those so gorgeous also some Kryolan aqua
color liquids which are like acrylics
and I'm gonna maybe water these down a
little bit and then do the paint's
that's of these okay how about you what
if you got over there so I have some Mac
lip mix which I guess will also be
really good for the plate paint
splatters
I've also got a Topshop ultra glass
which could be really interesting to mix
in with the different pigments get some
different texture in there sure I'm just
going to kind of play around so happens
okay let's do this we're doing is
getting my hair back out now I'm
straight in with the eyeshadow this
actually gorgeous eyeshadow oh my god
right
I'm literally packing on this Pat
McGrath eyeshadow yeah all over the base
you know what gives you really good
coverage
Oh laughs is eyeshadow name what's your
next thing you're gonna do then I'm
gonna get busy with the paint's I'm just
gonna but I think I'm gonna really wash
them down I don't think they're gonna
flick I know they're quite fluent those
I'm gonna walk them down a little bit Oh
shadow everyone's working working
it's like paintball for the face but
like mine isn't mind looking like blood
splatters oh I'm making McDonald's after
too many dreams
oh my favorite look oh I failed I failed
this isn't funny
I don't know how to I don't know how to
flatter ah oh now that love you know I
looks like blood splatter and what got
the going is like literally so thick
okay right this is awesome
Oh two minutes two minutes okay right do
it I know and lipstick hands look at my
hands okay this is just lovely right
one minute we look at it okay right
don't get it on get it on
I've got more on my body and my dress
but I do on my face
30 seconds Oh officially Rowand five
seconds five seconds
no okay round three your hands let me
see you oh I can't I love nyonyo I can t
remember I've I look like I think I've
just blocked it out it went so wrong I
mean let's there's paint on everything
on so much I struggled with um
everything
ya know what it was getting the flakes
on how did I do it what was your
technique flicking back the brush so
that it kind of landed on so I started
with that yeah because you've got
something really big I put all your hand
sides of your hair everywhere
well yours is very arty and delicate
yeah little green smudge there I just
found it I don't know what color to do
next
no looking individual on forgetting and
going off on it yeah I didn't even get
to the lipstick didn't even get that
thank you so much for watching this
week's final face off I really hope you
enjoyed it as much as we did who do you
think did the look better or do you
think we're both winners definitely
don't forget to subscribe to glamour
UK's and YouTube channels for more
videos just like this
[Music]